the first thing we want to do is we want
to analyze the horizontal asymptote and
the way you do that is you look at the
highest degree term in the numerator and
the highest degree term in the
denominator and you analyze their powers
their degrees so in this case the
highest degree term here is this one the
highest degree term here is this one but
you can see that the denominators degree
is higher than the numerators highest
power term right and so what happens as
X gets larger and larger meaning as you
go to the right or the left okay on this
graph as X gets larger and larger like a
positive number or a large larger
negative number this is growing faster
meaning the deniers going much faster
than the numerator and what happens is
the fresh and overall gets smaller
smaller smaller approaches zero so for
these ones you're gonna get a horizontal
asymptote y equals zero it's gonna be
right on the x axis okay so it's gonna
be approaching that line now if you are
not sure not confident about it just go
ahead and pick a large value like say
you pick a thousand a thousand squared
is a million minus nine see the nine
doesn't make much of an impact it's
still like a lot of million and then
this was a would we say it was a
thousand thousand minus three the three
doesn't make much of a difference but we
have a thousand over a million which is
one one thousandth which is point zero
zero one so you can see it's getting
very small so you could approach it that
way by picking out a number a larger
number and seeing what happens but again
the degree here in the dimer is greater
than the numerator so we're getting y
equal to zero for a horizontal asymptote
now on this one you can see that the
highest degree term in the numerator and
the highest degree term in the
denominator do the same they don't have
to be squared they can be cubed or
fourth degrees and so forth but if
they're the same that means that this
term is growing at the same rate as this
term if these terms are growing much
faster than these two terms okay here so
if we cover those up but the graphs
going to behave like this as X gets very
large and because you're growing at the
same rate what we do is we get the ratio
of the coefficient so in this case it's
going to be one over to our horizontal
asymptote is going to be y equals
one-half and then the third scenario is
where the degree in the numerator is
greater than the degree in the
denominator here's where we get like a
slant or an oblique or a diagonal
asymptote and the way you would do that
is you would take this numerator and you
would divide it by the denominator you
could just do the long division and
you're going to get the equation of a
slant asymptotes whether this one I'll
just show you X is going into x squared
plus zero
plus one let's see x times X is x
squared if we subtract we're getting
let's see just one left over this is a
lower degree than this this would be
plus one over X but as X gets really
large this term actually goes to zero so
it's really in this case just y equals x
so we have a slant asymptote that looks
like this on a 45 degree angle or a
slope of 1 okay so that's the slant
asymptote so this is discussing the
horizontal and the slant asymptotes now
the vertical asymptotes what you want to
do you want to factor the numerator and
denominator as much as you can and the
reason is is because I'll give you an
example say for example you factor your
ok rational function let's say you get
something like this X minus 2 over X
plus 2 over X minus 2 X plus 3 now when
you look at the denominator that's how
you analyze the vertical asymptotes you
can't divide by zero so here you can see
that X can't be negative 3 ok X cannot
be negative 3 and X cannot be 2 and you
might jump to the conclusion a lot of
students do that we have a vertical
asymptote at 2 and a vertical asymptote
at negative 3 but because this term in
the denominator is cancelling with this
term in the numerator we're actually not
going to get a vertical asymptote there
we're going to get what's called a
removable discontinuity or a hole in
there raph you can check out the video I
did on that if you want to learn more
about the removal discontinuities but
for this video we're just going to talk
about the vertical asymptotes now and so
you're going to have a vertical
asymptote at x equals negative 3 so
that's going to be 1 2 3
and there's your vertical asymptote like
so so the key is you want to factor the
numerator and denominator if any factors
cancel out you don't get a vertical
asymptote at those values you just get a
hole so we're going to just cancel those
out we're gonna look at the other
denominator X cannot be negative 3 and
that's where your vertical asymptote
occurs so I hope this little video
helped you understand how to find
horizontal and vertical asymptotes when
you're graphing rational functions check
out some of the other videos I did
talking about graphing rational
functions to go a little bit deeper and
understand this even better
subscribe to the channel check out some
more Matthew do videos on Mario's math
tutor and YouTube channel and I look
forward to seeing the future videos I'll
talk to you soon